LARRY ARNN: The King is trying
to be all three branches.
But the person
who can be trusted
to be all three branches is
actually named in the document.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What is the general
rule, first paragraph?
SPEAKER 1: Well, it's the
fact that because of equality
and because all men are created
equal under the laws of nature,
they have the right to--
LARRY ARNN: Under the laws
of nature and nature's God.
Isn't that the first
authority cited in this?
Right?
And Christian over here
mentions two other places
where God is mentioned
in the Declaration.
What were they?
CHRISTIAN: They were where
it talked about endowed
with inalienable rights
by their creator, as well
as the end when we
pledge to each other
by the name of our
divine Providence.
LARRY ARNN: Divine
Providence, creator, laws
of nature and of nature's God.
Can you think of another?
No.
So the answer is, supreme judge
of the world toward the end.
So what branch of
government would
be the maker of the laws of
nature and of nature's God?
SPEAKER 2: Legislator?
LARRY ARNN: Lawmaker.
God is a lawmaker, right?
What branch of government would
be supreme judge of the world?
ALL: Judiciary.
LARRY ARNN: Yeah.
What branch of government
would be divine Providence?
ALL: Executive.
LARRY ARNN: I'll be darned.
And the creator would be
like a founder, right?
Like a Constitution maker.
Now, it's very
interesting that God
appears in these guises
and these images.
The branches of government,
one of the charges
in the middle of the
Declaration of Independence
is that the king, who's
the executive branch,
has interfered with the
legislature and the judges.
He suspended the legislature.
He has removed judges.
He has interfered with
the trial by jury.
The king is trying to
be all three branches.
But the person
who can be trusted
to be all three
branches is actually
named in the document--
only God, right?
It's very plain, isn't it?
Now, what do you mean
by a law of nature?
STEVE: Kind of rules that govern
how things should operate.
LARRY ARNN: You can
make it specific.
That's good.
That's very good, Steve.
And you can make it
specific this way too,
because if we say that a thing
has a way of growing, well,
under what conditions
does it grow well?
Plants need sun and
Sequoia trees need space.
Whatever makes it thrive,
that's the law governing it.
And the laws of nature
and of nature's God,
they're referring there
to this God that appears
three other times, right?
The one responsible for
the order of all things,
and also, the great
majority of them, the one
to whom they pray and expect
them to protect the revolution
that they're waging.
Not all of them thought
that God was so.
But many did, and
we're going to learn
as we go that it was a
specific purpose of the United
States of America to
be the first country
to make a complete, and full,
and happy home for people who
thought both ways about that.
Because their idea
was, those who
were Christians, who were
the great majority of them,
their idea was
you're never going
to get to heaven because
somebody passed a law saying
you had to do something.
SPEAKER 3: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.